what we're going to talk about in this
video is the expansion of presidential
power we've already seen that the
Constitution talks about the different
powers that a president would have but
as we've gone forward in history the
Constitution hasn't imagined every
circumstance that the president might
face and so there have been times where
the presidents have used powers that
aren't explicitly given in the
Constitution for example as early as
1803 you have the Louisiana Purchase
where you have Thomas Jefferson buying
land from Napoleon's France it does not
explicitly say anywhere in the
Constitution that presidents are allowed
to buy land from foreign countries you
fast forward a good bit to the Great
Depression
you have Franklin Delano Roosevelt who
serves four terms in office four terms
in office and also starts creating all
of these various agencies in order to
help stimulate the economy so it creates
agencies many of the things that he did
were not explicitly listed as powers of
the President and as you can imagine as
any member of the government especially
the president starts taking on powers
that aren't explicitly listed it might
make other people a little bit afraid
and so in reaction to some of this there
have been actions taken for example
because FDR had his four terms you have
the 22nd amendment and the 22nd
amendment says that no one can be
elected to the office of the president
more than two times and no one can serve
more than ten years in office that 10
years would come from if you take on
office in the second half of someone
else's administration and then you get
elected twice and so the 22nd amendment
was really a check on this type of
expansion of presidential power later on
you have things like the War Powers Act
let me write that War Powers Act which
is from 1973 and this is at the end of
the Vietnam War Congress has been
concerned how did we get embroiled in
this war a war that in the early days
did not
have any type of official authorization
from Congress but American troops were
put on the ground in a foreign country
and so the War Powers Act in 1973 says
that a president has to get
congressional buy-in within 60 days of
committing American troops but to help
us understand this issue let's go all
the way back to the Federalist Papers
remember the Federalist Papers were
written in an attempt to get the
Constitution ratified and for the sake
of this video we're going to focus on
Federalist number 70 written by
Alexander Hamilton in Federalist number
70 Alexander Hamilton makes the case why
you need to have a single individual who
has significant power at the head of the
executive branch and you could imagine
this would have been me this would have
made some people wary because the United
States had just gotten independence from
George the 3rd a king and so some people
might have been wary about Kings and
might have wanted maybe not one person
in charge or maybe a committee in charge
but this is what Hamilton wrote energy
and the executive is a leading character
in the definition of good government it
is essential to the protection of the
community against foreign attacks it is
not less essential to the steady
administration of the laws to the
protection of property against those
irregular and high-handed combinations
which sometimes interrupt the ordinary
course of justice to the security of
Liberty against the enterprises and
assaults of ambition of faction and of
anarchy a feeble executive implies a
feeble execution of the government a
feeble execution is but another phrase
for a bad execution and a government ill
executed whatever it may be in theory
must be in practice a bad government
that unity is conducive to energy will
not be disputed decision activity
secrecy and dispatch will generally
characterize the proceedings of one man
in a much more eminent degree than the
Proceedings of any greater number and in
proportion as the number is increased
these qualities will be diminished so
he's making the argument for
energetic executive and he's saying that
look it has tip that power it needs to
be in one person otherwise it's going to
be diluted amongst many and the more
people you have at the top of the
executive then these qualities of energy
of decisiveness are going to be
diminished and it's interesting he also
talks about secrecy which you don't
always view as a positive but maybe the
argument is if you're really to execute
well you don't have to tell everyone
what you're doing especially if you're
trying to conduct a war and you don't
want national secrets to get out the
plurality of the executive tends to
deprive the people of the two greatest
securities they can have for the
faithful exercise of any delegated power
so here he's further building the case
that hey if you have many people in the
executive at the head of the executive
it's going to deprive the people of two
great securities first the restraints of
public opinion which lose their efficacy
as well on account of the division of
the censure attendant on bad measures
among a number as on account of the
uncertainty on whom it ought to fall so
he's saying there are strengths of
public opinion don't work as well if
there's many people at the top if many
people are making these executive
decisions then they don't know who to
hold accountable they don't know who to
blame and secondly the opportunity of
discovering with facility and clearness
the misconduct of the persons they trust
in order either to their removal from
office or to their actual punishment in
cases which admit of it so once again
they're saying if the PERT if it's one
person leading the executive and if they
do something bad you can punish them you
can remove them from office but if it's
many people who do you blame it might
not be easy to hold them accountable but
then if we fast-forward to 1973 think
about the situation that the country was
in we were at the end of the Vietnam War
President Nixon was going through the
Watergate investigations and you have
the author Arthur Schlesinger jr. writes
the imperial presidency and it says
right over here the Pulitzer
prize-winning historian traces the
escalation of presidential power and
sitter's what Congress and the people
can do about it and here is an excerpt
of what he wrote
secrecy seemed to promise government
three inestimable advantages the power
to withhold the power to leak and the
power to lie so it's clear that Arthur
Schlessinger is not as big of a fan of
secrecy as Alexander Hamilton was the
power to withhold held out the hope of
denying the public the knowledge that
would make possible an independent
judgement on executive policy the
mystique of inside information if you
only knew what we know was a most
effective way to defend the national
security monopoly and prevent democratic
control of foreign policy so he's saying
look if you allow people to just not
tell you things they'll just say hey if
you only knew what we knew you would do
what we're doing but we can't tell you
what we know so you just have to trust
us the power to leak meant the power to
tell the people what it served the
government's purpose that they should
know so once again they can hold secret
and say hey trust us we're doing what's
the right thing but then they could
selectively leak so that only certain
information gets out that once again
could be in the interest of those in
power the power to withhold and the
power to leak led inexorably to the
power to lie the secrecy system
instilled in the executive branch the
idea that foreign policy was no one's
business save its own and the
uncontrolled secrecy made it easy for
lying to become routine it was in this
spirit that Eisenhower concealed the CIA
operations it was mounting against
governments around the world it was in
this spirit that the Kennedy
administration stealthily sent the cuban
brigade to the Bay of Pigs and
stealthily enlarged American involvement
in Vietnam it was in this spirit that
the Johnson administration Americanized
the Vietnam War misrepresenting one
episode after another to Congress and
the people Tonkin Gulf which was the
resolution based on a perceived attack
on an American ship which was later
judged to be just an explosion the first
American ground force commitment the
bombing of North Vietnam My Lai and the
rest
My Lai massacre is a famous massacre
that eventually got out and it showed a
massacre of civilians in in Vietnam but
I'll let you decide and it doesn't have
to be the case that Alexander Hamilton
was right 100% or that Arthur
Schlessinger is right 100% it could be
the case that well for the most part it
is important for an executive to have
some degree of secrecy even some of the
things that Arthur Schlesinger has
talked about where we're talking about
the Bay of Pigs or we're talking about
the CIA operations remember this was
during the Cold War
yet the Soviet Union out there with all
of its spies if it knew what was going
on it might be able to undermine
American actions so some degree of
secrecy absolutely was necessary but on
the other hand maybe there is a point
that sometimes that secrecy does allow
those in power to do things that would
make the general public very upset about
their actions